foreign
[Music]
management
and welcome you back to the technical
guide for startups where we are creating
a series of videos for technical
enablement to start build and grow your
businesses successfully and sustainably
on Google cloud in our previous videos
we talked about how to scale a cloud
spanner and how to optimize your Cloud
solutions for sustainability
and now we'll focus on our new database
alloy DB in this video we'll go through
the database portfolio of Google cloud
and where we can place alloy TP event
we also get an overview of advantages of
all idb talk about technical details of
alloy DB and why it is an unique
offering from Google Cloud
understand the concept better by walking
through a live demo and lastly we'll
talk about the customer use case
so let's get started first up we need to
understand the available options that
Google Cloud offers you to run your
operational workloads every customer has
different needs when it comes to
choosing the suitable database solution
you need to think about what kind of
data is stored how and how often it is
accessed and how it will be used
we can see here that Google Cloud's
portfolio covers different relational
nosql and in-memory option so find the
right fit for every use case let's dive
a bit deeper into the relation options
here we offer open source commercial and
cloud-first databases if you are
migrating an existing app or if you are
building a database with very specific
needs that map to an open source
solution the first two are the right
rest for you if you are looking for a
managed solution that is globally
distributed and strongly consistent you
should have a look into the third option
our newly added alloy DB database
combines the best of different worlds so
stay tuned and find out more in this
video
Cloud as we have seen the acceleration
of customers migrating their databases
to the cloud
we at Google are constantly working on
rethinking the technology they use
our customers want to modernize from
Legacy proprietary services and
standardize and open source
so we brought together all the benefits
of the postgres open source database
with Google's Innovation and created a
database ready for on top tier
relational workload
and we call it all idb
all this is done with preserving the
functionalities and the benefits coming
from most robust Community proven by
millions of users
for the postgres
what are the main six points that we
should keep in mind when deciding for
lldb Alloy DB is postgres compatible
supporting over 175 flex and 50
extensions so you can move your existing
apps without any code changes to loydb
is also highly scalable and can scale or
essentially up to 1000 virtual CPUs
that's about 20 nodes perdb cluster for
read connections this is also supported
by the horizontal scale out of database
optimized storage
the reason for my creating is easy our
performance test in March 2022 showed
that alloy DB is four times faster than
standard postgres SQL for transactional
workloads thanks to the underlying
caching and storage technology but more
about us later
the high reliability and availability of
four lines of SLA including maintenance
gives you an unique Advantage with all
idb
database is able to detect
and recover from most database failures
within the span of 60 Seconds
and this is regardless of size or the
load on the installs
alloy DB is also supported by multi-zone
and multi-region architecture
which gives you an almost seamless
failure in case of your region or the
Zone rails
thanks to all odb's non-disruptive
management operation the resizing and
maintenance can be also done without
much different disruptions to the end
users
is also highly scalable and can scale
horizontally up to more than 1000
virtual CPUs for read connections
this is also supported by the horizontal
scale out of database optimized storage
we have seen in our tests that alloy DB
is up to 100 times faster for analytical
queries compared to a standard stock
postgres
thanks to its columnar execution engine
engine leverages the technology for
faster scans joins and aggregations
this culminar engine is very easy to use
as there is no schema or application
change needed whatsoever
we automatically populate the column
store using machine learning to
understand your evolving query patterns
and continuously optimize the
performance of your relative database
let's think about Advanced machine
learning all IDP can support you here
through its autopilot systems helping
with automatic memory management
automatic vacuum management which is one
of the biggest problems in postgres and
storage tiering across multiple layers
and therefore ensuring a great price
performance balance on diverse workloads
it also has the index advisor feature
that can be used to recommend indexes
for your database by analyzing the most
frequent queries and improving the
database for their performance
last but not least we offer transparent
and predictable pricing there are no
license fees or OPAC IO charges and you
only pay for the storage that you are
using so if you drop a table you can see
the price going down straight away
now let's go a bit deeper and discuss
the technical details of alloy DB which
makes it a unique Cloud native database
most customers today run databases on
general purpose storage that is not
specifically designed for Boost gray SQL
and therefore not optimized for its
performance
with all ODB you get a storage which is
optimized to run database workloads
a key concept of all idb is
disaggregation of compute and Storage
this concept previously available on
expensive propriety databases
the storage is separated from the
compute node and has its own intelligent
software designed to improve database
performance and reliability
underline alloy DB is Google's massively
distributed scalable file system called
Colossus
the same system that is used for
billions of user applications like
YouTube and Gmail and also behind our
database spanner
the storage skills horizontally and
automatically
when a YouTube video goes viral and
suddenly a million of millions of users
viewing it
does the owner of the video need to tune
the database to support the workload
do you need to shut down the database to
repartition the storage
no the performance just hop and scaling
just happens out of the box
and that's what we have gotten into All
idb Storage
why should we and postgres SQL database
be different
as your transaction volume increases and
your storage needs increases
the scaling and performance just happens
you do not need to reallocate storage or
re-partition your tables you only pay
for storage what you use
you do not need to perform the complex
storage tuning or partitioning to get
the performance
the design of a Lloyd B under the covers
is quite different from other databases
in the distributed storage system is a
high performance synchronously
replicated append only logging system
transactions from the primary service
are locked to the system and written in
a storage step system to a secondary
compute node in another Zone
asynchronously
there's also asynchronous replication to
up to 20 with replicas providing for
horizontal wheat scale out
the database can be recovered directly
from the logs eliminating the need for
any checkpoints and performance delays
when the checkpoints occur
IO bottlenecks are automatically
eliminated
one of the key improvements in alloy DB
is that the checkpoint is not done in
the database tier but is moved to the
storage
a key to high performance is multi
layers of caching alloy DB provides
caching on multiple layers first in
memory and SSD caching with the storage
system second an automatically attached
SSD cache to each compute node called
the ultra fast cache the customer gets
the benefit of SSD caching at no
additional cost and without custom
configuration
third the in-memory buffer caching
provided by postgres
fourth an in-memory comma engine which
dramatically speeds up analytics only a
lloydb offers this feature in the
postgres world
engine is an in-memory store that is
automatically maintained by lloydb the
customer can turn the feature on or off
and can manually configure which columns
are included when the Seeker query is
performed in alloy DB the query
Optimizer automatically determines if
the data is in the Columbo story if so
it uses Advanced algorithm to eliminate
scans on Range searches to significantly
reduce the number of CPU instructions
required to perform the query if some
data is in the store and some is not the
optimizer automatically scans the data
where it is stored
you always get a consistent correct
answer that includes all data committed
to the database
in memory Commerce stores provide
extremely fast analytics with a low DB
you get the strength of Both Worlds fast
reliable performance for operational
transactions and extremely fast
analytics and operational data both the
Kamia engine you may be able to drop
indexes on tables that were used for
analytics with fewer indexes transaction
wide performance is improved
column store queries use far less CPUs
than queries that scan the buffer cache
or storage you may be able to get by
fewer virtual CPUs which may Cost You
Less as alloy DB charges by the virtual
CPU
let's have a closer look at the columnar
engine and why it makes analytical
queries so fast from technical
perspective
online DB uses columns metadata and
columnar filter to accelerate the query
processing
its machine learning models are learning
from both the content of the column and
the type of query operations that are
getting executed
learn metadata is used both to encode
the data values efficiently and to
accelerate the query processing
for example when a sync column that has
a small number of distinct values is
used in filters the criminal engine may
decide to generate list of distinct
values
as metadata this then can be used to
accelerate both equality and range based
filters
faster scans faster joins and faster
aggregations are achieved through
different techniques
the fastest scans are decided using
columns metadata that can store the list
of values for low cardinality columns
minimal and maximum values which helps
in column filtering
alloy DB uses Bloom filters to make
table joints faster if the join column
have high selectivity already uses the
power of vectorized filtering this means
filtering on a column of data that is
stored in a vector to reduce the number
of rows that needs to be processed by
the join operation
for optimizing query performance already
provides the maximum query performance
when using highly selective filters on a
white tables or when joining tables with
high selectivity
and last but not the least we have the
vectorize operations for the faster
aggregations
all idb can directly perform vectorized
aggregation operations on the columns
this means that it can perform
operations like some average and on
columns data without having to
materialize the entire result set
it can improve performance significantly
especially for large data sets a
selective filter is a filter that only
considers a subset of the rows in a
table and is therefore using an
inequality predicted
for example a query that looks for all
customers who live in Paris is a
selective filter because it only
considers the rows in a table that
contain the customer's location
information a less selector filter would
use viable scans and would therefore
need more query time a highly selective
joint is a joint condition that only
returns a small number of rows joins on
tables that are highly selective can be
up to 10 times faster as a low DB will
use Bloom filters whereas join on tables
that are less selective can be two to
five times faster in columnar scans if
that's chosen the alliedb query planner
uses a costing model to automatically
choose the best mode of execution for
each node in the query plan it can
either choose a columnar scan or a
traditional row format sequential scan
or even a hybrid scan
in the demo we are showing you how a
query performs way faster compared to a
normal postgres instance on alloy DB
those will give you an idea about how
you can Leverage The in-memory climaster
anole idb this caters to your needs of
having a htap database
in this demo we are going to show you
how a query performs way faster compared
to normal postgres instance on all idb
using its columnar engine
this will give you an idea about how you
can Leverage The in memory column Plus
store of alloy DB in your day-to-day
workloads
this perfectly fits in your needs of
having an edge tab database
I have logged in into Google Cloud
console
when you browse through the data
management section you can see alloy DB
listed here
for this demo I have pre-created an
allodb instance and loaded some data
into it using PG bench a standard
benchmarking tool for postgresh
and I have also added a read replica for
the alreadyb instance
here I have create a read replica
with the flag columnar engine set to all
so if you compare the two
instances of alloy DB the primary and
the date replica
the cpu's shape and size is exactly same
the only difference between these two is
the columnar engine flag
on the primary there is no such flag and
on the raid replica you can set see the
value is set to enabled
what we will do is we will execute a
query
exactly same query on the primary as
well as the date replica
and see when the data is coming from
columnar engine what is the query
performance you are getting compared to
executing on a normal business
if you click on the data protection tab
on left hand side
that is the place where you can
configure your backups either in a
continuous fashion
which will help you to do a prtr up to
35 days or you can have the backup size
per year on demand requirements of the
organization
we also have a tab on monitoring which
will give you insights like CPU memory
and utilization and iOS
for our demo purpose let's connect to
the primary and see what is the data
there how many tables are there what is
the volume we are executing the query
against
so let's connect to the primary
as here on the screen you can see that I
am connected to the primary instance
there is no flag enabled I can show you
the tables
here are the tables into the schema let
me show you the number of Records in it
here are the number of Records in this
table now let's execute a single query
on this table
and see how it performs
before executing I'll just enable the
timing so that we know how much time it
took to execute
[Music]
fantastic
now we know the time it took on this
primary instance
now let's go to the
replica
where we have enabled the columnar
engine
and execute the exact same query and see
the difference in the timing one
interesting to note here is alloy DB
can create read replicas with its own
terminal cache so that means you can use
your differently cars with a different
columnar cache serve a purpose of
different departmental queries so here I
am connected to the red replica
I just made this screen as a brown so
that let's not confuse it with the white
screen which we used for a primary
now you can see the exact number of same
tables
here you can see exact number of sim
records in that table
now let's execute the same query with
setting the timing on
boom the query is out already so you can
see it's not only 100 times faster but
it's much more than that let me show you
the value on the white screen and here
is the value
of brown screen and you can see there is
much more difference how performant the
query balls with the already basic
culminar engine I am sure you want to
try this feature and see the impact on
your queries
so go ahead and spin an alreadyb
instance on Google Cloud you have seen
the powerful columnar cache demo now
let's see how our customers find it here
are some of our customer references our
Precision Beauty Tech startup b4n
transform their business with our lordb
as before and scoring it faced the
challenge of scalability in the database
as queries took seconds to complete
by integrating alloy DB in its core
technology platform B for n was able to
reduce their query Time by 90 this means
from 12 seconds down to 1.2 integrate a
fully managed service that resulted in
time and effort saved on managing the
infrastructure and setting up and
configuring the database and last but
not least they were able to cut their
costs as an alloy D you only charge for
what you use and there are no
traditional license fees
they will like to close with this light
with all ODB now
Google cloud is the preferred and best
home to run your postgresql workloads
you can run and fully manage vanilla
postgres instance on cloud SQL
if you need an Enterprise class features
of postgres then alloy DB and if you
need a global scale with Finance of
availability
spanner with the postgres interface is
the answer
want to find out more check out our
guides and documentation you can find
some links in the descriptions and get
your data moved to lydb we're looking
forward to hearing your success stories
we'll see you very soon in our next
video where we'll cover how to architect
a blockchain startup thank you for
joining us today in this episode to
continue exploring alloy DB check out
the links in the description don't
forget to like this video And subscribe
to our YouTube channel and click on the
Bell icon to get notified each time we
post a new video we hope you are as
excited as we are to get on board with
this journey hang tight and we'll see
you very soon on the other side
foreign
[Music]